you've done a lot of stuff in your
career if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why oh my god of that I was in uh
oh God
I think the Americans is pretty great
mid to the end of the of the Americans I
would say
uh yeah I'm a big fan of that show and
speaking of the Americans was it a pre I
was surprised uh it seemed like it was a
prerequisite of being in the Americans
to be in cocaine bear it kind of was
that was something that um Banks said
she just tried to get as many characters
as many actors from The Americans as she
could
three is pretty good yeah I was um did
she was this like being serious because
it really is like a reunion
no she she knew Margo from a project
they had worked on together and then
when she brought it up to me
um I got a text from Margot saying are
you doing this movie and I was like are
you doing this movie
another time we called him and she's
like yeah I'm gonna undo this movie and
I was like what now I'm definitely
[__] doing this movie
um because I was like oh my God the
thought of Margot being the the park
ranger I was like oh I I get the whole
thing now to me she's my favorite thing
in the whole movie and then Matthew
we were getting ready to go to Ireland
and Matthew knows Banks from many many
years ago and he said who's doing the uh
the part that part at the beginning and
I said I don't know he goes text Banks
and tell her I want to do it and
Elizabeth was like yes please she was
like okay
so this is one of those projects like no
BS I really can't believe it got made
because no no I know it's just one of
those where I'm like I just can't
believe it but what was it like for you
actually reading the script for the
first time and seeing what they were
going to be going for I just thought it
was that crazy enough do you know what I
mean you also like we were if at the
height of kovid like I think we'd
probably been through about a year and a
half
of the worst of it the beginning and it
just felt
so intense and everything felt so crazy
and heavy and um and to read something
like this
I was just like
It's gotta work I mean it just felt like
such an escape and such a romp and
um
and Liz had an idea for it you know she
had a total
tone idea that she she was going for and
when she told me that she was getting
Margot I was like okay
I I see what you're doing and why not
movies have been around for over a
hundred years and it's very rare to make
a movie through a big Studio where you
do you're doing something that has
really never been done before I think
that speaks to Liz I mean
first of all
Elizabeth has such a um
like an easy confidence in her she loves
this business she's so um like one of
the first things I remember her from is
Wet Hot American Summer her playing that
like trashy girl like making out with uh
Paul Rudd
she just has she's been doing it for so
long she's such a pro and
um she's sort of unflappable in that way
like she believes in herself and that's
a really good quality as a director and
I just feel like she had a vision for it
you know she loves the gore and like the
craziness of those kind of movies and
um and that's what she so she did not
shy away from the gore at all and I
think that's what makes it this crazy
wacky
out there movie and
and I think in a time where we're all
kind of like not going to the theater as
much this is one you can totally go sit
with a ton of people in a crowded room
and laugh your ass off and be scared and
grossed out and it's just like a total
fun ridiculous ride and I think that's
what she wanted to create and it's like
what she's perfect for I agree
um there are some amazing and nasty and
bloody kills in this movie
um when you were watching it for the
first time because obviously there's so
much of this is going to be CGI when
you're watching it for the first time
which was the kill that you were like
get the F out of here oh my God so many
Margot and Jesse and I
oh into a screening room and there was
so many
I I mean Jesse's death is
pretty amazing pretty amazing and we
were just crying screaming laughing
margot's face being drug uh on the um
asphalt pretty great
um
the ambulance workers being like thrown
from the ambulance
amazing
I mean we were we were shrieking and
clapping and laughing and crying that's
pretty much me in the theater I was
howling
um I again I was just like I couldn't
actually believe how I was Bloody yeah
because I haven't spoken to to Elizabeth
yet but I am curious like how the MPAA
was like yeah go for it that was always
her her tone that was always her desire
and she loves those kind of movies so I
think she was just like no I want it to
be gory and gross and scary and totally
ridiculous
the thing is in the movie you are
basically playing everything straight
while the craziness is around you so
what is that like actually mostly you're
just trying hard not to pee your pants
in that pink jumpsuit because that would
be very visible it was helpful to be the
straight person because Jesse who's so
good off the cuff like Liz
um they're so good at one-liners and
just they were improving all those jokes
like those are just like coming out and
Margo is really good at that too so it
was in a way it was helpful to be the
straight man and just let them rip and
kind of be their Watcher I wanted to
talk about something else I'm a big fan
of Scott Burns and you are you are part
of his upcoming I believe Apple series
um can you sort of talk about it because
it deals with the environment and which
is something that I'm basically could
you sort of talk about it and what you
drew you to the project yeah Scott um
Burns uh is so talented and he's a
friend of ours and uh wrote this
incredibly beautiful
um
moving
Anthology sort of it's It's a limited
series and
um what he was trying to do which is
huge is
to personalize
what's happening to get people to
see that it's going to affect all of our
lives and he's just written such
beautiful stories I mean they're so
um moving and about relationships and
animals and like our life and it's you
know it it seems like it's set in the
future and
you by the time from the time we made it
um to now I mean it's it's happening so
I think he made a very poetic beautiful
um take on that and every episode is
sort of its own little world and I'm in
I'm a very small part in this um episode
that takes place all in India and so
it's uh I think I speak the only English
in it
um but it's really
uh just epic and beautiful and uh
important
I'm really looking forward to it
congrats on cocaine bear and thank you
for making me laugh